Ralph Breaks The Internet is bursting with
pop-culture easter eggs and references as
well as in-jokes poking fun at Disney itself,
but on top of that, Disney also drops in some
sneaky gags making fun of their own fans!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to reveal 5 ways
the Wreck-It Ralph sequel totally trolls Disney,
Marvel and Pixar fans!
My Funko Pops giveaway is also running on
this video, so hit the bell and tap the Gleam
link in the video description to enter.
When Vanellope arrives at the fansite Oh My
Disney, she discovers Groot taking part in
an Ask Me Anything Q&A session, which is amusing
because, of course, all his answers are "I
am Groot".
The first audience question comes from a fan
who has shades of The Simpsons' Comic Book
Guy about him.
And who manages to create some ear-piercing
audio feedback on the microphone in his desperate
quest for an answer to the following question:
"In Captain America: The First Avenger, Red
Skull refers to Yggdrasil, the World Tree,
guardian of wisdom and faith; are we to believe,
Sir, that you are a descendant of that tree?"
Groot replies in his inimitable fashion and
the Marvel fan thanks him!
Of course, Disney are poking fun here at comic
con Q&As and all of us Marvel fans who love
to spend time online connecting all the dots
between their movies and coming up with sometimes
wild theories about the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
By the way, the obsessive Marvel fan in Wreck-It
Ralph 2 is voiced by Jason Mantzoukas whose
character in the film is called Hey Nongman,
which is a catchphrase on the podcast "Comedy
Bang!
Bang!" which features Mantzoukas.
Talk about deep-cut references!
After Disney officially announced the movie's
title as Ralph Breaks The Internet: Wreck-It
Ralph 2 back in March 2017, there were loads
of comments on websites, forums, and social
media suggesting that a better title would
have been "Ralph Wrecks the Internet" as that
better reflects the original film and its
title character.
In fact, it seems that the online laments
about the title were so loud that they reached
the Wreck-It Ralph team at Disney who decided
to have a bit of light-hearted fun by mocking
both themselves and their fans in the movie's
trailer where Ralph asks the question on everyone's
lips.
"Shouldn't it be Ralph Wrecks The Internet?"
"Yes, since he is Wreck-It Ralph."
"Ah, yeah, but 'Break The Internet', it's
like a 'thing'!"
"Right, it's just 'wreck the internet kinda
sounds better', doesn't it?"
"Hmm, you're not wrong."
Apparently, the filmmakers did originally
consider calling the film Ralph Wrecks The
Internet, but ended up going with "Breaks
The Internet" for the same reason Yesss gives:
because that's the expression!
Pixar fans will doubtless have enjoyed seeing
many of their favourite characters and easter
eggs show up in Wreck-It Ralph 2
Indeed, Pixar gets its own section at Oh My
Disney with the animation studio's signature
desk lamp and Luxo ball adorning the area.
There are also cameos by EVE from WALL-E,
Arlo from The Good Dinosaur, and Buzz Lightyear
is there meeting and greeting fans.
And Pixar's Brave princess Merida also features
in the Disney Princess line-up when Vanellope
breaks into the restricted backstage area.
However, the Disney animators couldn't help
themselves from throwing a little bit of shade
at Pixar and its fans in that scene.
"I gave my Mammy a cake, she turned into a
big bear, my auld yin tried to do her in."
"If that's no a pure mess I don't know what
is."
"Eh."
"We can't understand her."
"She's from the other studio."
Apparently, the filmmakers did originally
consider calling the film Ralph Wrecks The
Internet, but ended up going with "Breaks
The Internet" for the same reason Yesss gives:
because that's the expression!
Now, the princess scene does poke fun at many
of the Disney princess tropes we've seen over
the years, but Disney does seem to be having
a bit of an extra laugh at Merida and Pixar.
I'm sure it's definitely got nothing to do
with the fact that Brave won the Oscar for
Best Animated Feature Film over Wreck-It Ralph
at the Academy Awards in 2013!
For anyone who found Merida's Scottish accent
difficult to follow in the trailer, well,
brace yourselves because Disney goes even
further in the actual movie as Merida's new
lines are delivered in an even thicker accent
so you're going to have an even tougher time
deciphering what she says in the final film.
The entire Disney princess scene is, of course,
very funny, but some Pixar and Scottish fans
may feel a touch upset at Merida's treatment.
By the way, if you'd like to check out all
the other Disney princess easter eggs in Ralph
Breaks The Internet, I'll add links to my
video on that at the end and in the video
description.
OK, spoilers ahead for the end credits which
are basically just jokes, so no story spoilers.
If you think back to the first trailer Disney
released for Ralph Breaks The Internet, you'll
likely remember it ended with that poor exploding
bunny in the Pancake-Milkshake game.
"Eat, eat!"
"Err, Ralph you might wanna try feeding the
kitty for a little while."
"No!
The kitty gets the milkshake, the bunny gets
the pancake..."
The filmmakers include a deliberate nod to
that horrifying trailer scene in the new film
when Ralph makes a video unboxing a Pancake-Milkshake
fun set.
However, by the end of the movie proper, there's
still no sign of any exploding bunnies; just
a few images of the game's cute cat and rabbit
in the fancy credits!
So, that trailer scene must have been cut
from the final film, you think to yourself!
But you're wrong!
Disney has actually been trolling you, and
they reveal their master prank in a mid-credits
scene!
The scene starts with a mother asking her
daughter if she enjoyed the movie, and the
little girl replies,
"Weeellllll, there was a scene in the trailer
that wasn't in the movie.
And that makes me sad."
So, the mum suggests the little girl play
a game to cheer up, and that game is – yes,
you guessed it – Pancake-Milkshake!
Cue the previously missing trailer segment
with Ralph and Vanellope force-feeding pancakes
to a helpless bunny in a scene reminiscent
of Mr Creosote in Monty Python's The Meaning
of Life and Violet Beauregarde in Willy Wonka
And The Chocolate Factory!
The Wreck-It Ralph sequel team were obviously
having a bit of fun with their fans, especially
the kind of movie lovers – you know the
ones – who enjoy finding out all about scenes
or characters deleted from movies as well
as alternate endings and any big story changes
during the filmmaking process!
Well played, Disney, well played!
If you stick around till the very end of the
credits, Disney has got another rick-diculous
surprise for you that ties in perfectly with
the movie's online setting.
Yes, after all the credits have rolled, a
voice announces, 'And now, an exclusive sneak
peek of Frozen 2!'
But if you think your patience is going to
be rewarded with a special glimpse at the
Frozen sequel, then think again because the
voice also tells you to 'click here', and
although you'll hear some brief orchestral
music, the screen quickly changes to Ralph
singing and dancing along to the chorus of
Rick Astley's 80s hit Never Gonna Give You
Up, complete with back-up dancing from Fix-It
Felix and Shank's crew!
Yes, that's right, Disney just performed that
classic pranky online bait-and-switch, the
rick-roll, on us all!
And, as if Ralph rick-rolling us wasn't enough,
the video-game bad guy also talks directly
to the audience.
The way Ralph breaks the fourth wall in this
post-credits scene and tells us there’s
really no reason to stick around in the cinema
any longer is a nice homage to John Hughes’s
classic 80s comedy Ferris Bueller’s Day
Off, which was also received a tribute in
the first Deadpool movie
The way Ralph breaks the fourth wall in this
post-credits scene and tells us there's really
no reason to stay is a nice homage to John
Hughes's classic 80s comedy Ferris Bueller's
Day Off, which also received a tribute in
the first Deadpool movie.
Of course, this isn't the first time a character
in the Disney stable has trolled those of
us who stay right through the end credits
– I'm looking at you Captain America in
Spider-Man: Homecoming!
"Sometimes patience is the key to victory."
"Sometimes it leads to very little."
"It seems like it's not worth it."
"And you wonder why you waited so long for
something so disappointing."
Now, what were your favourite moments or jokes
in Ralph Breaks The Internet?
Let me know in the comments below and remember
to subscribe and click on the gleam link in
the video description for a chance to win
an awesome Wreck-It Ralph Funko Pop.
Congratulations to the winners of my Bohemian
Rhapsody giveaway!
Send me an email with your details so I can
get your prizes sent out to you.
Tap left to check out all the easter eggs
& gags you missed in the Disney Princess scene
or tap right for another video you're sure
to like!
And if you enjoyed this, remember to share
and leave a thumbs-up for more videos like
this.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!